[Music]  this will be the final word  in the story of Skywalker  [Music]  starwars the rise of Skywalker get  tickets now this Christmas it's okay  it's okay that to us  [Music]  [Applause]  starwars the rise of Skywalker this was  not yet rated confronting fear it's the  destiny of a Jedi your destiny if this  mission fails it was all for nothing  [Music]  we're not alone good people will fight  if we lead them  [Music]  your journey yes it's in  our Wars the rise of Skywalker tickets  available now  oh we've done all this time we're doing  there's repeal taking one last look sir  at my friend  [Music]  confronting fear  is the destiny of the Jedi your destiny  we're all in this  tool and Star Wars the rise of Skywalker  tickets available now  [Music]  confronting fear is the destiny of a  Jedi  your destiny  [Music]  the force will be with you always  [Applause]  tickets available now  you